hi i'm ryan right today I'm going to be
covering movie news that I found
interesting for the second week of jun
2015 the official plot for Batman vs
Superman has been released it confirms
that Batman and Superman will be versing
each other but that a new threat arises
putting mankind in all kinds of danger
the threat Batman and Superman
contemplating homosexuality Jon Bernthal
will play The Punisher and the upcoming
season of daredevil The Punisher is a
vigilante who gets the job done no
matter how lethal it is which includes
coming on your girlfriend's face asa
butterfield is reportedly out of the
running for spider-man because like an
idiot he talked about it before getting
authorization from the gods of Marvel
Chris Hemsworth signs on for a role in
the Ghostbusters reboot as the male
receptionist meanwhile his brother Liam
Hemsworth will be starring in a movie
that no one cares about it's been
revealed that the Power Rangers movie
will have its villain be read Oh repulsa
looking at this photo of rita repulsa
you can say that she is also vagina
repulsa netflix acquires original phone
war machine starring brad pitt first we
had Terrence Howard then Don Cheadle no
Brad Pitt
I'm kidding it's not it's not that war
machine carragher James Cameron is
supportive of Terminator Genisys and
says that it is the real third film
internet folks have been seeing that
Cameron was probably paid to say those
words yes the man who has co-written
produced and directed the two biggest
box-office hits of all time needed the
extra cash she would tell a jewel for
the guy from 12 years a slave is Baron
Mordo and Marvel's Doctor Strange I
don't know much about the character
other than the fact that he's black the
director of the grey joe carnahan may be
directing bad boys three boys three is a
necessary film because Martin Lawrence
is who is he again that's right that's
my point no one [ __ ] remembers [ __ ]
perfect three is on its way yeah of
course it is all right guys well that's
it for my movie news of the week you can
tune in next week for more movie news
you follow the real rejects on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine and you can
check out my videos on Latino Review com
and despite what you white people might
think it is not run by gangsters